[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm link and i'm
rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we are doing something very
exciting something new we're going to be
listening to your voicemails in response
to our prompt
i was today years old when i learned
fill in the blank
and so our new number one eight eight
eight
don't leave out that eight ear pod one
one eight eight eight six ear pod one
what is it again i wanna sing it the
same way oh i don't 1 888 earpod one
uh yeah that's and is that it so this is
our new line where you can call to
answer the prompts that we usually put
out on twitter in this case this was a
twitter prompt that's how you can like
know what we were asking you but also
any comments any questions any
observations any corrections any hopes
and dreams whatever you want to leave on
the line you can do that mm-hmm i like
the idea of that i like the idea of
hearing your voice
and don't be shy
call in let us know something keep it
short now listen
i'm a spring something on you here
and i do want to hear
the thing that you wanted to tell me
about because i am excited about hearing
about it okay but and you probably know
where i'm going with this people always
ask
like
when they when they want to get asked
like good questions about
like us working together and like
being friends for so long like do you
guys ever
do you guys ever fight and let me tell
you
oh we just had a fight
i would call it a fight
oh it was i mean we caught a fight on a
0-10
scale of intensity
what would you say that the what i'm
calling a fight before we came in here
was
i have a number in my head 10 being the
time that we slapped each other and
almost got into a physical fight tim
bean if we were fighting and then we we
did start it did get
physical which
that's never happened i'd say it got to
a six
well okay yeah i was thinking it yeah it
could have been a seven
it's like i didn't think that the
podcast was in jeopardy
but that was part of it
that i mean it was on it was on the
table but i didn't think it was imminent
i didn't feel like it was about to like
go off the rails
so why don't i i just think
i think i think we should share
you know people want to know about us
fighting you want to give my perspective
it's very fresh
i'm gonna even let you go first uh so
i'm not gonna maybe strategic i'm not
gonna give the details about what we
were arguing about because
um
it would be a be boring and b would also
like reveal something that we're working
on that's true yeah i don't wanna
so
uh
we had a conversation about this thing
yesterday
and i was
i
i was concerned about it not cause
anything with you but just like
concerned about some details that are
kind of changing about something and
it's just like it was on my mind i like
went home thinking about it and so then
and i was in the meeting too and i was i
was also concerned about it in the
meeting right
so
um
i have a tendency to
like
i would just say exactly now you may
think say what happened yeah yeah well
no i know well i'm gonna i'm just saying
i think because i think this is uh i
think the the argument is based in our
differences in approach to these things
so
we were getting ready for the podcast in
the wardrobe room i was putting on a
little powder can you tell
um
and i was like you know i'll tell you
i'm kind of concerned about filling the
blank
and
blah blah blah blah blah blah
and then what i heard from you is just
like
you shouldn't be concerned about that
that's not a big deal it's being handled
that's what you said what i heard from
you is that
i don't want to get into this right now
because we're about to do a podcast and
i don't like to open up a can of worms
before we go into performance mode which
i respect by the way and ended up
telling you that i do respect it yeah um
and i think it's this but it got heated
first
well because what i said was because
because there was a there was literally
a moment where you said well what are
you going to do about it like when we
were when we were talking about the
concern and i was like oh okay we're in
that place again where
what you are expecting from the
conversation
is if we're going to talk about
something let's talk about it let's have
a real conversation about it and let's
solve the problem my brain doesn't work
that way my brain is just like hey i'm
thinking this right now and i'm putting
on some makeup and i'm just gonna say
what's on my mind
just
because hey this is something that uh
we're gonna have to solve eventually
let's i'm just thinking about it i'm
gonna talk about it yeah and you know
what i'm thinking about but not talking
about
this
right like what i was like what we're
about to do oh we're doing this the
first time we've ever done this like i'm
thinking about this like i'm thinking
about the details of it and like
you know trying to perfectionize it you
know getting into the weeds and so when
you got so i'm dabbing my face can you
tell
with some with some powders
so many powders good god
um yeah and then you you get multiple
you bring up the thing and then i'm like
you know what i realized there's a part
of this well remember the other
conversation we had
about filling the blank that then
mitigates the concern that we have that
i felt like i felt like okay
my buddy rhett here is getting
up in arms like he's concerned about
this i bet you i bet you he was thinking
about it last night i bet you this is
the first thing we're talking about this
morning so it's like he might have been
he might have not slept at all he might
have been thinking about this all night
and i'm like you know what there's a
mitigating factor about filling the
blank from another conversation don't
you remember that
that like i actually didn't think about
it
and you were like well i was in the
meeting but i don't remember hearing
that and i'm like
well
i really think
it's it's being handled and that was
helpful information and i don't think
i just don't think we need to worry
about it what i never said was
you know what i'm not in the headspace
to discuss this
can we can we pause this like i did not
do that instead
i will own the fact that like
i was the one who escalated it i felt
like you were
you were in
uh an elevated state of alarm
that i thought was detrimental to the
task at hand this podcast i felt that
now you you told me that i was wrong
i respect that
so
i felt like i need to protect where we
were going
and so i told you something that wasn't
was not a was not a deflection or a
coping mechanism but it was a an actual
opinion based on facts that
this is not something to be alarmed
about so basically my first
communication to you was
calm down
which then your response was
even though i didn't use the words calm
down your response was
well listen you telling me to calm down
is
that's the only thing i'm upset about
because i actually made you mad i wasn't
that made you mad yeah because i wasn't
upset
never in the history you know the saying
in the history of calm down calm down
doesn't happen telling somebody to calm
down got him to calm down and that that
really set you off so then all of a
sudden you were at the place that i was
trying to get you to not be because of
what i said and then
i'm like oh god now i gotta now i get
now i'm now you're mad at me
and then i'm mad at you because you're
mad at me because i'm doing it you just
i think someone's spitting in my eyeball
right now listen don't play the victim
well it just happened
don't play the victim you're mad at me
because i'm trying to
protect
i'm trying to put you at ease she's
trying to calm you down and so i don't
need to be calm
the lesson learned for me which
what was the next step that's not the
end of the fight people want to know
about the fight
um
i i simply said when did the arm
wrestling come in well i simply said
there was no armor wrestling
i mean first of all i said that i was at
that point you were mad well and then i
was like i know i have a look on my face
that i'm also very mad and i can't hide
it no and what i said was is this feels
like
what is what um
happens
not infrequently
which is just like
you're getting on the track of hey i'm
about to do the podcast and i i'm on
that track right now
and i have
reconciled the particular concern that
you're bringing up and i've put it in a
place in my brain that minimizes my
anxiety related i've compartmentalized
something that could bring me anxiety
you are trying to open the compartment
right before i go and do something where
i want to be in a certain mind space and
so i was like and i and this is what i
say now i respect that because
it's i don't that's not how my brain
works so i don't so i forget sometimes
because i'm not thinking about it
because again that's i'm not i'm i think
i'm thinking about the podcast but i'm
also thinking about the problem at the
same time kind of back and forth and
then i'll you know if i was operating by
myself it would be like okay i can have
this intense
thought process and then immediately
detach from it and come in here and go
into performance mode and i don't think
that's
true across the board in every
circumstance oh yeah which i referred to
another one where we both agreed that
that wasn't the case yeah i'm not saying
i'm impervious to it but it frustrates
you when something's on your mind that
we should talk about and you want to
talk about it and you find yourself
talking about it and then i'm putting up
walls where even though i might have
good
reasons for why
it's like
i'm i should dissolve the uh concern or
of the subject matter you feel like it's
just a wall and saying nope i don't want
to talk about this and me exerting
control in order to protect myself which
frustrates you because you're just like
why can't we just talk about whatever
we're thinking
and or whatever i'm thinking
you know in that moment and
then i'm interpreting it as judgment
that you're like
oh
so is this a is this a low blow that i
can't multitask huh if i was as if i was
as skilled as you are this is nothing
you're actually saying or even believing
this is something that i project on you
that like you're judging me for not
being as
multitask
able as you are
and i'm like well it goes a lot deeper
than that and then i'm defensive about
something you haven't even leveled at me
so then
oh this is really it's really getting
nasty and that's why i guess this might
be an eight in my mind really
i i felt like it was i ultimately i felt
like it was healthy because yeah me too
because again
if i had to do it all over again i would
be like okay
while
i may like oh if i if i think if i
thought about this a second for a second
i'd be like oh if i bring this up right
now
then that's a cue for link to have a
conversation that we sought that we
solved the problem
that's not what i'm thinking i'm just
like just kind of just think i'm just
thinking out loud
so if i had to go back i would be like
okay you have this concern but
we're about to do a podcast don't bring
it up
wait until it's and there's another
moment
but and you
turned the conversation to that in the
moment which you know what i appreciate
that i think that's when that's when it
started to dissolve a little bit
i think the only thing i did was to try
to to try to
settle things was i was like you know if
i thought that you were alarmed and i
thought there wasn't a need for alarm
for
concrete reasons that i told you
so i wasn't just trying to give you an
empty calm down but i know that's
infuriating so i'm sorry
that my message came across that way but
if i had to do it over again what i
would have done is because i don't i
would have said
like i said you
now's not a good time for me to engage
in this problem
i do have concerns about it
but i also i don't i don't think i'm as
concerned as you are but i don't want to
be
so
let's table this conversation
uh
and
and i would just ask could we do that
because i also don't expect
for you to just be
walking around on eggshells with
everything you think trying to
anticipate if it's a good time for for
link to be able to handle it you know
it's like i don't want to be that guy
and i don't think it's fair for you to
have to
if the onus isn't on you i would say
it's a nice 50 50. so i think we're if
we both redid what we said then that
would have been a beautiful thing i
think
and i do acknowledge that if we would
have done that you might have been the
one that experienced more frustration
than me which is interesting
if i hadn't brought it up and you said i
don't want to talk about this right yeah
and you've been like oh and then if you
would just be like okay
you would have experienced a little bit
of frustration
but i wouldn't have
so
it's not about right or wrong it's not
about like who's got skills that the
other one doesn't have
or
you know
so i feel i feel good about it now
and you'll feel good about it when when
you get more clarity when we actually
talk about it some more
um
yeah but i know but i think this is good
because it's a it's a reminder to not
um
again i i don't think it's a
walking on eggshells thing necessarily
but i know that i have a tendency to
um
because this is the way if you were just
to isolate the conversation in my brain
apart from anybody that i'm talking to
it would be like
um
so many
disparate thoughts popping into my brain
at all i probably have some form of mild
adhd i don't know i've never been
diagnosed and i don't want to
take that from somebody who actually has
has it but that's not how adhd works
there's not like a certain number of
people i mean i don't want to you know
belittle someone's experience because i
have a family full of people with adhd
but um
and so
yeah it's just a reminder that it's just
like okay i can't exp i can't bring it
because i'm not saying that you're the
problem because it's because it's not
because you care just characterize it as
uh oh you've got you're you're you're
you've got you think you've got skills
you didn't say that but you said that's
where your mind could go is that you
think you've got an ability that i don't
have i don't see it as
because technically multitasking is not
a real thing right like you actually
can't do two things at once but there's
a switching between things very quickly
uh that people
i don't know whether
if you have a brain like mine whether
that adhd or not like switching between
things very quickly is just the way that
your mind works
but that becomes difficult
when
you're interacting with someone whose
brain doesn't work in that way and
you're doing like 12 different things
and it requires like certain emotional
uh
readiness to like do something like this
so
to me it's just a it's not i wouldn't
say it's a frustration
to bring it up and then be told that
it's just more of a reminder it's like
okay yes we we have we'll have an
opportunity to talk about that at
another time so i'm sorry for bringing
it up
when i did
well i don't feel like i should forgive
you because i feel like it was well i i
appreciate the apology i forgive you as
much as you need forgiveness whatever
that means
ah i need to be sorry for something now
you already already apologized for what
uh
for
[Music]
i can't remember exactly
[Laughter]
well you see
oh you did you forgive and forget or did
you just forget
well because i'm i'm i wasn't you know i
got mad in the moment or not me i got i
didn't get mad in the moment i got i was
like okay i don't it feels like i'm
you're trying to control me right now
that's the other part of it is that like
i don't feel like i was
like
ironically the thing that i wish i would
have done would have been more
controlling like let's not have this
conversation right now
you know there's a better way to do it
but that would be more controlling i
feel like i was misinterpreted as being
controlling when i had real reasons to
say
chill out and i didn't say i think you
are necessarily i said
it feels like one of those moments in
which you're trying to
say something to yourself but you're
saying it out loud to me
and addressing a problem that i'm not
currently experiencing
and you're trying to control and that
was out that was only 50 of it
and yeah so it's and i thought you were
being like i projected on you you were
being superior you were projecting on me
that i was being controlling because we
know
each other's
well i'm not going to say that's a
weakness of yours but that's
that's a way that you're
that you can be perceived or even
misinterpreted
and yes i am controlling but not
everything i
a lot of it can be misinterpreted as
control when it's something else and yes
i am superior and that can be missing
so i'm just kidding and now in an effort
to
further control
this podcast
i kind of feel like
do we want to go into this because
should we table it for the next i think
we have to table this now the thing that
i was prepared to cause i want i want to
give it to you to make you laugh with i
want to give it it's due but i'm ready
to laugh
i'm
flexible you know i was i was really on
this track to do this bit
that i planned but i'm so flexible and i
can move so quickly from one thing to
another because we're at this point in
the podcast we haven't heard any
voicemails i'm going to move on to the
voicemail i mean if we keep this up we
won't hear any voice it's not a problem
i'm letting you know it's not a problem
to take me off of the track should we
hug it out there is no track my mind is
an ice skating rink not a series of
railroad trucks i'm should we you know
what i'm saying there's a difference
maybe we should constantly riding on a
zamboni hand-hugging throughout my mind
can we there are no tracks something to
have some sort of just like
emotional conclusion should one of us
cry what about just like a three-finger
handshake
okay it's worth it there we go
all right that's what you do when you're
when you don't want to hug it out but
you want to say it's over three fingers
and a thumb i'm glad we did that
what are we promoting today
we're promoting
best friends back all right stevie's
podcast that she does with her uh high
school best friend
and the reason not only are we promoting
it because uh we think you will enjoy it
if you enjoy podcasts where two friends
are connecting but this particular
episode that just released is especially
special because i was on it
uh
you know i'm not saying anything about
me necessarily i'm just saying that if
if you uh think that you would enjoy me
having a conversation with two women
uh one of them make it about that
they'll love that uh one of them being
stupid hey
i'm rhett you like hearing me talk
how much more would you like hear me
talk to two women it's like
what a great way to promote they're
gonna hate that they're gonna they're
gonna delete they're not gonna they're
not even they aren't tv's not gonna
listen to this uh promo
but she sure as heck listen to my
conversation with her i guess because
she was there
uh yeah so we talked about school lunch
which was my favorite time of the day
jason what we're saying is if you're
listening to this you can at least
tolerate rhett
so uh you know you know you'll be able
to do that on
stevie and nagin's show
and then you might start realizing that
you should be listening to their show
instead of ours
but hopefully you have room for both in
your life it doesn't work like adhd
right
all right
all right
okay let's listen to our first voicemail
hey red link it's mitchell i was today
years old when i learned out that kokomo
wasn't a real island
i feel lied too
okay thank you for keeping that short
mitchell so um we're talking about the
beach boys song which it was called
kokomo yeah aruba that's real jamaica
that's real you've been there oh i want
to take you to bermuda that's real
bahama i've been there bahama bahamas
bahama is a real bahama i don't know if
it's real bahama is one of no grand
bahama is an island oh bahama come on
pretty mama
too
that's real that's real montego that's
really been there
you been there
montego bay
baby why don't we go down to coca mo
not real
we'll get there fast i mean how do you
get somewhere fast it doesn't exist and
then we'll take it slow
that's where i want to go
way down the clock way down to coca mo
you're adding an extra syllable because
they did in the thing but kokomo is is
what it is and just when you speak it
uh
i gotta say as someone who attended a
beach boys concert with my dad in which
i danced with two drunk middle-aged
women and also watched john stamos play
the drums he's still at it uh
i already knew this
uh you already knew this yeah
i was maybe you know i was probably in
my 30s when i learned it you got to say
i was i was 33
years old
when i learned that kokomo wasn't real
that's pretty old uh and just to confirm
that this came out when we were like 10
or 11. the most reliable website that i
usually get my facts from is beach.com
you know when you search so i'm going to
let you know just so you understand our
sources here
i googled kokomo isn't real and then
that thing that's a biased search that
google throws up there to kind of give a
little summary from a website without
you having to go to that website this is
what it says yeah yeah yeah i love that
as far as we can tell there are
there were no actual islands off the
florida keys or elsewhere in 1988 as far
as we at beach.com can tell
that we're named kokomo there is a
kokomo indiana
probably not talking about that there's
also you'd have to be north of indiana
to go way down there's also a kokomo
island in florida
island island in there you go in quotes
but it is a tiki bar named
for the song so it came after
so oh uh it seems that co and then this
is where beach.com is really beginning
to uh take some license
it seems that kokomo is more a state of
mind than a real place
[Laughter]
okay so you know yeah it's like but when
you're singing that song to your date
and then then there's like all right you
should pack in their bags
and then it's like well before you
packing your bags for this is just a
state of mind
you know brian wilson is gonna
is gonna have to endure some some some
wrath you think about how many people
because first of all that song more than
any other song
makes you want to travel to the
caribbean and it really just gets you
and
how many people
have google kokomo because it's like
well they mention a lot of places that
sound awesome but the place they really
want to go is kokomo i mean that's why
they named the song that and that's why
the chorus ends with it yeah and then
you look it up and you more people
google kokomo with the intention of
visiting it and then finding out that it
isn't real then probably any other
uh fantasy place because people aren't
like googling atlantis thinking they can
get a flight there they know that it's a
it's a place that doesn't exist like
this has to hold the world record for
most
searches with the intent to travel to
and then to find out that it's not a
real place can can you can that be a
world record
name another place
i wasn't listening to you because i was
reading google yeah i can't name another
place if that's what you're asking uh
kokomo is from the 1988 film cocktail
which i haven't seen it was not it was
written by
john phillips scott mckenzie mike love
of the beach boys terry melcher
i'm just trying to figure out why
like what
the lyrics described two lovers taking a
trip to a relaxing place on kokomo a
utopic island off the florida keys
in addition to the fictional kokomo the
song also makes reference to unfictional
places
uh gotta make it seem real
yeah but i'm just trying to figure out
it sounds like a place kokomo like why
why did they do this it's i just think
it's their genius mike love stated that
wilson
was not on kokomo because eugene landy
wilson's therapist turned collaborator
refused to let brian sing on it i mean
brian wilson did not sing unless landy
was a producer and co-writer okay that
doesn't get too so brian wilson had
nothing to do with it right
oh the group later recorded a spanish
language version of kokomo with
participation from brian wilson
hmm
but we're not really getting to
like you're trying to get to like the
heart of the why like the why but let's
just move on i think i think today we've
learned enough about kokomo let's play
another one
you ready
hi lincoln rhett my name is sarah and i
was today years old when i learned
vanilla extract has over 35 alcohol in
it i knew there was some but not that
much do you all know that
i didn't take care i did not know though
so it's 70 proof
it's because because you double the
percentage yeah um in case you needed to
learn that today
65 water
good gracious 35 alcohol um
let me hold on so it's 65 water and 35
alcohol so
all the vanilla part is alcohol um
according to the fda vanilla extract is
a mixture of vanilla scent and flavor
characteristic and alcohol to be exact
that fda requires
an ethyl alcohol content of at least 35
for a product to be considered vanilla
extract
but because it's not a characterizes a
beverage it's not regulated so you can
just buy it off the shelf and yes there
are articles
um addressing the fact that kids
are getting drunk off this stuff how
okay you take a few
extract is
doled out first of all it's usually
dulled out into baked items that are
going to be cooked and at that point it
doesn't matter right could i put it into
well this is cooking it i put it in you
know this little secret i put it into my
pancake mix you know if you're making
pancakes you put a little vanilla is how
i say it when i'm doing it on saturday
uh you put a little vanilla into the uh
into it and it makes it taste great my
kids have never gotten drunk because
we're talking about drops and then we're
cooking
no but you can get a big you can get a
big uh bottle of it definitely but think
about how hard that is to drink
well i mean if you take a couple of
shots you can get drunk
well i think you deserve it if you've
done that think about how hard it is to
drink
vodka i mean
what yeah it's it's got the same alcohol
content of jagermeister
all right
jagermeister is not great at bite so i
think that's easy to drink i don't know
if i've ever had it
um kids are coming up with new ways to
get a buzz and this is just one of the
ways they're doing it how does it work
exactly according to kidsactivities.com
apparently kids are going to the grocery
store heading out of the baking aisle
to buy a small bottle of bourbon vanilla
extract
yup
last year many news stories about
students sneaking into school with this
undercover alcohol
mixing vanilla extract into coffee
drinking it and then heading to school
where they are buzzed i mean
i just have
i listen i know kidsactivities.com is a
great website
uh i just have a lot of issues with this
i i just don't
what i don't think you can put vanilla
extract into your coffee at the levels
that are tolerable to make drinking a
cup of coffee worth it and get drunk is
it really happening yes is it really
happening chris thomas a drug counselor
with the wayne county mental health
department told the wayne times is that
wayne county north carolina uh i don't
know drinking the vanilla extract is
similar to drinking a strong
vanilla-flavored cough medicine
yeah not fun
scissor
if you think vanilla extract is harmful
you should know that pure peppermint
extract contains 89 alcohol that's even
harder there we go and pure lemon
extract is 83 alcohol
both these extracts can cause
intoxication so i mean choose your i'm
just a flavor i'm just saying it's best
to talk with your teens to inform them
that they can do this as a parent
this is dangerous and it's not worth
being peer pressured into trying as a
parent i do not believe this is
something that we can be we should be
concerned about well as a parent i
believe that when you talk to him then
there is to today i learned
that day i learned how to get drunk how
to get drunk without today i learned one
more way to get drunk being carded
hey i mean knowledge is power
let's listen to the next one
all right here we go
hey rhett and link yo um
i have a couple of today i learned
that
were actually happened
like a few minutes ago and i saw rhett
tweeted this and i was like that's
perfect
um
my boyfriend informed me that the
mask and the halloween franchise is just
a william shatner mask
painted white
literally had no idea that is terrifying
and the other one
i was thinking about when i was at the
grocery store
was when you're buying half a chicken
you're sharing a meal with someone else
someone else is eating the other half of
that chicken
and it could be a stranger
probably i guess you could buy two
halves of the same chicken
that would be like a whole chicken
yeah but you understand what i mean
all right love the show bye guys wow
thanks for loving the show
see this is so friendly yeah i don't
think she said her name
i think she did well we'll call her
claire because i don't remember thanks
claire
being a fan of the show for
for giving us a twofer i uh let's start
with the chicken and that feels more
like a shower thought
than it's a day i learned yeah it's not
something that like it's not a i mean
it is a fact i guess
and uh it's a it's more of a realization
you know today i realized and i think it
ultimately applies to basically
everything in the grocery store in some
ways like
you know when you get a can of corn
well somebody else got a can of corn
that's probably got corn from the same
cob in it you probably have corn from
yeah you're hundreds of cobs you're
sharing you're just probably sharing
corn with thousands of people i mean by
that definition how many cows
are in a burger well it depends on the
burger the mcdonald's is going to be
potentially thousands a single package
of conventional ground beef might
contain meat from 100 400 even a
thousand cows yes there have been
studies that have found traces of dna
from up to 1 000 cows in a single
package of ground beef and how am i
supposed to feel about this
i feel nothing
i feel nothing about it well do you feel
i mean like i don't have to feel
something about everything
what's behind the question right
i guess in one sense you know
by spreading out the impact across
multiple cows it's like one cow is not
suffering as much as a thousand cows
so you're saying they pluck a little bit
that's not how that's not how it works
they'd pluck a little bit and say we'll
come back for you uh this is not we the
vegans are not gonna be happy about this
point of the conversation uh yeah half a
chicken i'm a proponent of plant-based
meat and also lab-grown meat which i
believe
uh i'm excited about personally
yeah um
i'm excited about your excitement for uh
but you know we'll talk about that years
and years to come uh the second part of
this
i knew did you know about this shatner
thing i knew about this i think you
learned this at the same time around the
holiday of halloween people are talking
about like halloween trivias
so talking i i think it
i remember the story being they're
making halloween the movie and they
needed to get a mask and like somebody
like a prop person like went to
a store and like grabbed a mask
and it was a william shot i can give you
the story link another website star
trek.com
okay this is official this is an article
from the website rick sternbach an
illustrator and designer on star trek
the motion picture the next generation
deep space nine voyager and nemesis okay
posted the following on his facebook
page a few years back writing
there are a number of historical threads
through various production people over
the years that validate that i've got
one of those threads here i've told this
story once or twice before i was hired
as an illustrator on halloween 2 in 1981
working for production designer j
michael riva in a supply cabinet at
pumpkin pie productions we had one mask
left from the original halloween and no
idea where to get any others for the
sequel
it appeared that we'd need to go check
out some of the toy stores and such but
i noticed that there was some wording
molded into the neck area
there was a model number
and don post studios i made a call
read off the model number and the word
came back it's our captain kirk mask
i asked if we could buy a number of them
and was told we'll give you a box just
give us credit with that i turn the
official dealings over to the higher ups
brush with greatness so apparently in we
it's michael myers i don't know we
haven't said michael myers but that's
the michael myers mask is a william
shatner mask and it was used
uh
there's a death mask created for star
trek
so i mean a death mask
well does death mask mean something that
i'd i guess
it probably means something that we
don't understand because we don't know
anything didn't you learn to speak
klingon that one branch you went to uh
but i think ultimately what it is is it
was like a mask to be used on star trek
when they needed someone to look like
william shatner
being dead or you know it's basically
it's like the mask you put on a stunt
double that you when you want him to
look like the person well they cut his
the eye holes bigger and and it makes it
look less like william shatner like i
can see the william shatner death mask
here
i think they enlarged the holes and they
also took the hair which was combed into
a william shatner part and they did it
straight back which is unsettling so the
michael meyer's straight back here
wow okay
but we already knew that claire
that's i know that's your alias
we love you
all right another
i was today years old when i learned
evergreens were called evergreens
because the trees stay forever green
yeah
yeah there's a reason you didn't give
your name
because that is freaking embarrassing
why
i think it's one of the it's not that
she thought it was called evergreen for
another reason it's just something you
never think of it's just that's just
what it's called evergreen
but it's a it's a word without meaning
that just i picture a pine tree i feel
like there's like three
things that i still remember from
elementary school and this is one of
them you know what i'm saying deciduous
trees
i mean i do know that but i think that
that you're getting a little bit more
advanced
i think thank you two of the three
things that i that i remember from
elementary school
the first is that if you carve your name
on a tree four feet up and the tree
grows another hundred years it'll still
be four feet up
okay okay
because of the apical meristem because
of the apical meristem
and the second thing is the evergreen
stays green all year
i mean it's like what else could it mean
yeah it's just like
gee
yeah you don't have to give your name
right and there's it makes it harder for
us to personalize us making fun of you
mythical beast
coming through and you know what that's
the whole point though it's like it's a
bit of a confession i was
yeah when i learned that evergreen meant
that well it's it's a beautiful thing
for for them to be so
for them not to shed their leaves i
prefer it
you know but the thing is is that they
do shed
i mean i they don't yeah they do go into
a pine forest and just see how many
pine needles are on the floor of the
forest my papa cut down he had these
like all the he had like a pine forest
in his lawn there in
in lillington
and and hobby damn ah but um if he
didn't
william shutter he was just
he was so tired of like having to scrape
up all these pine pine needles that he
just cut down all the trees i was like
they were it was beautiful do you think
they shed their needles at a at a steady
rate throughout the year or is there a
moment of shedding and they're just
immediately replaced
man we are really good while you're
looking that up i will say speaking of
william shatner a moment of shedding
for pine trees uh so if you've watched
inside eats our show on the food network
you know that we do voice over and we
are kind of like you know we're talking
about what we're doing when we're doing
it and
uh because uh you had to go back to
north carolina
uh for lewis's funeral
we actually had to do our voice over
sessions separate
i did my voice over session at a place
in burbank and you did yours in raleigh
somewhere
at different times
right i did it in fayetteville
fayetteville vietnam some sort of better
some sort of like
a bunker it was kind of a bunker
um
by getting that
yeah stay tuned i was uh sitting in the
chair there and going and getting
getting ready to go and do my vo
and the guy the operator engineer was
like you know who was sitting in that
chair yesterday
william shatner
really
and then he said
did you feel his butt imprint he was
like
can you
can you smell the fear
yes i can smell the fear but do you know
why he said that because no
he the engineer
having done this for many many years was
afraid so intimidated by william shatner
that he was like
i'm sure i leaked fear into this room
can you still smell the fear from
yesterday
he i guess
i mean
and after the fact i guess he was
validating that he's an intimidating guy
i've seen william shatner uh two times
during my at a restaurant during my los
angeles
living what was the second time
another restaurant i think it was
another restaurant okay he'll eat
he will he eats just like the rest of us
you know how he puts on his pants
well he teleports into him yeah exactly
uh although longleaf pines do retain
some needles year-round in years with
normal rainfall individual bundles of
needles generally remain on the tree for
two growing seasons
and are shed in the fall so they do lose
their stuff in the fall they just do it
every two years and it's immediately
regenerated you feel good about this you
feel like we learned you feel like we
learned enough here
yeah let's move on
i was today years old when i realized
that uppercase letters are called
uppercase because typesetters used to
keep their capital letters in the top
box therefore uppercase okay this is up
all right so
i was today years old when i learned
this one we've we've we've hit one so
there's two they have two cases
at least two there's a there's a
uppercase and a lowercase that holds the
typesetter holds their their
things
nobody needs to know this
um
you're just trying to be stodgy you're
judging this it's like you know they
didn't know this
it's cool lowercase uppercase
man isn't it isn't it great that we
don't have to do that now that we have
typewriters
um
how do you what do you what's your
general feeling about uppercase letters
in general
um
i could do without them
i don't really think they're necessary
think about it that's kind of what i was
getting at yeah
uh i mean you definitely i'm a fan of
punctuation
and i cannot stop putting two spaces
after every period that i typed i've
noticed that i cannot stop it's like i
you told me i don't know it might have
been
nine months ago and that that was a big
by the way
uh i was today years old i was 43 years
old when i learned that now you don't
have to space twice after the end of a
period at the end of a sentence like i
did not know that well an interesting
and it makes total sense because why
well there's a period i think that our
typing instructor
spacebait i think even in 1990 it's
muscle memory before when we were
learning in space base
one thing to me we were learning that in
1994 i don't even think it was important
at the time
i don't think it's like oh it's changed
that much since the 90s i just think it
was never that important to do
but it was technically correct according
to one school of thought and we happen
to go to that school yeah and once i'm
graded on something i just can't on
i can't unlearn it
but like in general
i think the only good reason for upper
case i just want to clarify once i'm
graded on something i completely forget
it
of course you're normal but that's what
all unless it's muscle memory
and then it's like once i'm told the
right way to do something even if it's
wrong it's really hard to undo it
especially in muscle memory that i think
that's like a military technique
the only valid reason for uppercase
letters is passwords
you can't even convince me that they're
necessary for like proper
proper nouns
look john stamos okay let's talk about
him again i try to do that as much as i
can
you write john stamos and you don't
capitalize the j and the s you think i'm
confused
you might be referring to john stamos
the impersonal noun
exactly
it's like uh if you're going
it's if
if you're traveling south to kokomo
you might encounter
uh john stamos
which is just
it's kind of like an oasis it's not
johnson instead of water it's a pile of
drums
um
i mean i'm just look at john stamos i'm
sure there's there you know and you can
use one eight eight eight your pod one
or two to explain this to us but like
just i know i'm just probably wrong
about this but it's like you think we
can get by without them i think we can
get by without them
i think we can get by without him can we
thrive without him
defend the uppercase
188 earpod one
wow today i learned
that coffee cake isn't actually cake
flavored like coffee it's cake you eat
with coffee is that it
you done
okay
i think i always knew this i don't think
i don't think
coffee cake is not made of coffee
well i could see how it is it's not it's
also not it's just not flavored like
coffee it doesn't have a there's no
espresso it's not tiramisu it's it's
it's to be it's an accompanist to a
company coffee yeah i guess in fairness
you know how i know this
because you've never eaten it no because
i have eaten it oh and it doesn't taste
like coffee
do you like it i do like it
i like it because it feels it's not as
sweet
i don't like sweets that are too sweet
especially
i don't know it just makes me feel a
little better
and i like some it's a moist thing it's
a little it's got some crumbly stuff on
top and there's some ribbons that's like
it's like sugar it's like
it's it's like like granular sugar stuff
on top
and then it's but it's real moist on it
i like a bready dessert you know
well i think it was when i ate it as a
kid
my mom would have it
and i always felt like i was eating
something that was intended for adults
only
yeah it was like drinking vanilla
extract straight
you know what i mean it was like this is
an adult dessert coffee cake
kids are not supposed to have this you
got at least
your balls have to have dropped
in order for you to really partake in
this legally
you know it's what it felt like for me
but it's not true it's just no that's
not true yeah yeah because it goes with
coffee and you're not really supposed to
have coffee as a kid
even though like shepherd's been having
a cup of coffee in the morning since he
was about
seven really and just in case you're
wondering if it causes uh
the stunting of the growth
i was looking at the wall the other day
when we started measuring shepard
with the little ten years ago no well in
the in the house you've been at the
beginning of the no at the beginning of
the pandemic
it hit us shepherd it seems to be
growing we should do that thing that
people do in their houses
where you like mark their heights we had
never done that
and uh it's in the kitchen just on the
wall in the kitchen that's one of my
biggest regrets it's not even in like a
pantry just on the wall in the kitchen
not doing that
shepherd
has grown
[Music]
from
five two to five ten
over the course of the pandemic
okay and actually i think it made me
great
because we started growing we started
measuring him after he had already
gotten a little bit about that in less
than two years and
there was one there was one part where
it was like jesse had done like july
to
august okay so
no it was three months it was july to
september so two months
two months is what i'm trying to say
because it was a seven something in the
nine something and he had grown
over one inch
i think you know when you talk about
growing like a weed there's some like
apparently there's this seaweed
and it's off the coast of catalina with
your little scuba stuff you might be
able to go see this okay um
it's called it's actually a big deal
don't call it my little scuba stuff
with your big scuba stuff it requires
lots of
um
testing know-how certification i just
don't want to dance
i don't want to talk about it because it
makes me anxious okay bladder seaweed
think it's called
yeah the ones that have the bulb i guess
i think it grows like
12 feet a day or something like that i
don't know i'm not gonna do it today i
learned about this you can look it up at
beach.com
but
um yeah shepherd shot up that's your
point but no but you can see it growing
and i think that if you're going if a
person is growing an inch in two months
i think you could probably catch it
on like an iphone well that i mean
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah forget putting notches on your wall
just do a time lapse with your iphone
yeah there's a time-lapse feature yeah
there's a certain i mean i i remember
growing pains i mean you definitely
have
some some pain if you're growing that
fast because i didn't that's not what
happened with me i didn't i remember i
wasn't normal and then tall i was just
tall out of straight out of the womb
like two like three years
into my life i was already tall and so
there was never it was just always a lot
of growth but not i mean he said he had
a growth spurt yeah he came out of
nowhere yeah it's wild man
my name's abby
um
calling this one is for
link oh
no
yeah um
today i learned that in the u.s
peanut butter must contain 90 peanuts
otherwise it has to be called peanuts
bread
so
yeah
just
remember that
thanks abby so
peanuts i mean but
where do you get peanut spread i mean
what even is peanut spread have i been
eating it i mean jif is
peanuts bread
i would think it's you know that there's
that brand of peanut butter where they
mix it with all kinds of different
things like oh there's the peanut butter
with chocolate and there's a peanut
butter with so and so i think that they
probably have to call that peanut spread
because they're messing up their
percentages
oh i mean what else could you put in
peanut butter coke
i'm talking about cocaine
why would you talk about that i don't
know because this feels like we grew up
in a time where that people were just
putting cocaine in different things
protein peanuts spread yeah i mean it's
like if there's
like i'm shopping for peanut spread now
yeah it's like when you've got
dark chocolate in it
well that earth balance right there
we've had that before click on that and
that's got coconut in it yeah it's got
coconut in it that's why
creamier tasting lighter spreading
fancier topping i mean we need to send
this over to spork i want to know what
the best peanut spread is
because i like the idea of of a good
spread you know
spread
um
yeah this is intriguing i mean there's
some there's some good-looking peanut
spreads but because it's a mixture of
other stuff sinister labs
makes a peanut spread
honey grim cracker
oh yes honey cinnamon flavored
peanut
spread
yep he's got the other stuff in it so it
just can't be peanut what do you think
is more important
uppercase letters or the people who
determine that you can't call something
peanut butter unless it's got 90 like do
you like
what do you think would change if that
person didn't exist i think the
regulations need not apply to peanut
butter but they do
it's just like one of those things where
it's like the the the regulations aren't
to protect people from peanut butter of
course there is the allergies but if
you're getting peanut butter and peanut
spread you're going to be allergic
either way i think i think it's for
other things where it's like
you just can't call something something
people buy it think they're eating it i
mean that's pretty important maybe not
for peanut butter
like certain cheeses okay so i know you
can't call something cheese unless it's
actually cheese and technically american
cheese is not like a craft single or
something is not american cheese so it's
called cheese product or something like
that yeah
is that important
i mean maybe it is again i'm just i'm
asking the question
people
i do think there's places where it's
important but i still don't know if
cheese is one of them
okay so i don't know what it is it could
be i don't know
a certain point
it's the truth in advertising yeah
if it's if it's some sort of medicine
yeah let's limit it i mean it's good to
know though i mean it's like uh because
now i've just opened up my palette you
know i also like peanut butter spreads
it feels like some of these things may
exist so that you could say say you
could talk about it at a party
and this is not the kind of thing that
you want to party talk peanut spread
yeah yeah this is not this doesn't meet
the criteria kokomo not being a real
place that's party talk that does oh you
you know
peanut butter has to be 90 peanuts are
you if it's not it's peanut spread are
you really saying that guy should be
asked to leave the party that this part
of the podcast is starting to suck is
that really what you're saying no
everything that we say doesn't have to
be repeatable at a party because then it
just all becomes one big blur so this is
not party talk it's like you got to have
some ebbs and flows you got to have some
dynamic range to your conversation i
don't think it's bad i'm just saying
it's just not party talk it's just
something to take to your you know your
own brand you're right
what you just
heard was the boring part of this ear
biscuit episode that's not what i was
saying now you can appreciate this next
recording hello
my name is jessica and i was 20 years
old when i learned that a cloud can
weigh over a million pounds due to the
amount of water that can be found inside
of it
have a great day everyone
directed directed out to the audience an
awareness that this would be played
for millions of listeners millions yep
of listeners
have now learned i mean through her did
you give her name
yes jessica with all the cloud facts
millions of people have learned through
jessica
that you a clown can weigh a million
tons
a million pounds well and i gotta get a
listener
well i can verify it link you don't have
to play it again oh good uh
znews.india.com
they have clouds as per research an
average cumulus cloud weighs an
incredible 500 000 kilograms or 1.1
million pounds the equivalent weight the
average one well that's just an average
that that makes it even more party talk
you know the average it's not that a
cloud could it's that the average one
does the equivalent weight of 100 plus
elephants a lot more than you think
right okay listen you don't need that
clouds may look so light and fluffy but
the fact is they're actually quite heavy
and then the question that follows is
well
if they're so heavy why don't they fall
and then it's like ding ding ding ever
heard of rain
got him
can you still say got him yeah you just
did it felt appropriate yeah
man
cause you did if they're heavy why don't
they fall
ding ding
[Applause]
but you better follow up with something
everybody needs to hear it's very
condescending you know if you're gonna
ding ding somebody at a
and party uh
uh yeah it's like it seems like
something you'd try
[Laughter]
don't have i mean it's one thing to say
calm down in a fight there's another
thing to ding ding somebody in the fight
i've never offended anyone at a party
it's just like what's the point of this
fight anyway ding ding ding ding ding
you know it's like try that with jesse
next time you guys get into it that
sounds like
yeah it sounds like you're trying to end
the fight with the [ __ ] with the bell
uh if you're in a fight
and you go to the corner
oh
they also start
the rounds don't they yeah they do both
yeah so it's really hard both ways
ah
okay
but i just think you should try it in a
fight
because it's in a game show way it's all
about the tone
moving along
hi um my name is leah and i was today
years old when i learned that when put
into water
limes
uh they sink the lemons they float i'm
not saying limes are witches but i'm
also not not saying that
okay have a good one bye
oh god now this aaliyah
this
feels
not only like something that you would
talk about at a party but something you
would demonstrate
and then after you got done with it
you'd be like ding ding ding
which that's optional
which one of these are these gonna float
or sink and then everybody would be like
are we that drunk
ding ding ding you know like
yes that feels like a magic thing to do
is it real
did you follow this one up
limes and lemons both have densities
that are very close to water so you
would expect that they would both float
ding ding ding however
however limes are slightly denser than
lemons which is why they sink in lemons
float
huh
across the board i wonder i mean there's
got to be outliers you could probably
find a floating floating line floating
lime that'd be a good name for a bar in
kokomo
the floating lime
yep tonight john stamos
solo drums oh there's a mildly
interesting reddit thread about this
i see a picture right here
the lemon's at the top wow
and it's in one of those flavored water
things
that's kind of cool like if you've got a
clear
uh water spigot
container you get the lemons are at the
top and the limes are at the bottom so
it's like a demonstration i love when
they put fruit in water like that in
like a hotel lobby dang there's some
good water
they should put fruit in water towers
there's probably a community out there
that's considering that well i think
that might like somewhere in the
northwest progressive place well
do you hear about that little city
outside of portland they got
strawberries in the water tower well
some i mean everybody's loves it my
hydra flask you know my trusty big black
hydro flask
never leave home without it
well it went missing and then all of a
sudden it turned up and i started
drinking out of it again and i was like
fruity
it was fruity there was like a residual
fruit in it and and i'll tell you
someone
obviously hadn't had fruitified my
hydroflask and it took somebody this is
weird somebody at your house somebody at
my house put some and it might have been
like
put they put tea in there they did
something with it this doesn't seem like
something that could happen to your
hydro flask i know your own
because it's always on my person
i don't know that's troubling do you
know who did it no i
you know why i didn't ask
because you kind of liked it because i
kind of liked it i think you're on to
something
put it in the put it in the water supply
i mean they put fluoride in there to
control our brains why don't they also
put fruit flavor in there i think we can
sneak somewhere
around here in l.a it's like just
just south of the just treatment plant
we're climbing up a water tower like
those kids who are gonna deface it but
we just have a big bucket of
strawberries we're just trying to like
spice up people's like just fruitify it
a little bit
i mean i wasn't complaining i was like
wow and it took about it took a long
time to get rid of that taste
and now i miss and miss it i mean i mean
i think like six weeks this is why i
drink lacroix i only put water in my
hydro flask so i don't have to really
wash it
i wash the cap but like
you don't have to wash out fruit
fruit's clean
we need to verify that before we would
load it in the water tower well i'll
just search right now it is fruit it's
fruit cleansing it's fruit clean
yeah germs on the peel or skin can get
inside fruits and vegetables when you
cut them washing things
that's a myth uh fruit or sterile you
heard it here
with soap detergent or commercial
produce wash is not recommended by the
cd you can rub fruit on an open wound
is the water in fruit clean fruit water
how could we like what we could call it
we probably do need to face the take the
name of the town off of the water tower
and just put fruit water on the on it so
people know that what we've done here's
an article do you really need to wash
fruit before you eat it this is a men's
health article of course this is this is
what men if you're a man
you really gotta look like a dork and
like put this
apple under the sink
now i'll wash a tater that's obvious
because it's so it's a root vegetable
it's been in the dirt ding ding ding
ding ding an apple's just been in the
air okay okay yes i know about
pesticides don't
you know don't call 188 earpod
one and let us know that hey rhett and
link yeah
first time uh today i learned a pretty
interesting fact that if you speak
buffalo eight times in a row it
grammatically counts as a sentence and
it would sound like
buffalo buffalo buffalo buffalo buffalo
buffalo buffalo uh have fun with that
one what okay it grammatically counts as
a sentence because buffalo
can function as every part of speech
it can be a noun
it can be well that's an animal
of how do you ver why is buffalo a verb
i don't know look it up dictionary.com
it could also be
an adjective
it could it's also a place
buffalo new york
um
the verb for buffalo
is
to overall or intimidate
someone she didn't like being buffaloed
okay there you go
so buffalo
i don't see an adjective okay i i think
i can figure this out
buffalo buffalo so these are buffalo
from buffalo okay yep buffalo buffalo
buffalo so those buffalo from buffalo
are doing the act of buffaloing buffalo
other buffalo yep
so we're four deep now
i don't know where to go we're done
buffalo buffalo
so that's buffalo from buffalo buffalo
buffalo buffalo buffalo other buffalo
from buffalo so now we're five deep what
buffalo buffalo buffalo they verb
buffalo buffalo buffalo five
five
but no there's nobody but fellow
but no no no no no no no
uh
i'm sure it's somebody's name he's a
really
buffalo sentence
we're not just gonna take your word for
it oh you know what i think we just
figured it out link it's not eight it's
five a history of the sentence buffalo
buffalo buffalo buffalo buffalo from
william j rappaport my favorite rapaport
oh is that michael's
older brother the author oh no no look
see also
so the history okay the original one was
five which we just got easily so may 4th
2008
buffalo buffalo buffalo buffalo buffalo
buffalo buffalo buffalo i think i did it
eight times
is also he was right sorry to doubt you
for a second okay so um
it so it was originally okay so this is
what it is the parts of speech okay oh
here's a sentence diagram link
oh i i love diagramming sentences
so this
traditional sentence diagram of this is
okay here the part parsed out as a
description
those buffalo buffalo
whom
buffalo buffalo buffalo what
well you i think you have to says to
crack the code of this mystical combo
there are diagrams articles and videos
all over the internet some can be
helpful others make an already confusing
sentence even more convincing
well that settles it for me
you know what
i'm not ready to talk about this
i'm just not in the right headspace
i think you've got a good question here
but i'm not ready to answer it because i
need to perform well on this podcast
well here is here is another this is how
you can
this is how you can understand it bison
from buffalo new york who are
intimidated by other bison in their
community also happen to intimidate
other bison in their community
that's what the sentence means
so it's buffalo buffalo
buffalo buffalo buffalo place buffalo
buffalo
i don't know how the you get past i
don't know what happens
we only need three more buffalo from
buffalo but yeah buffalo buffalo oh
buffalo from buffalo
buffalo buffalo from buffalo
do the bison one again so it's like
let me let me do it
buffalo bison buffalo buffalo bison
yes then what buffalo
buffalo bison
that's yeah that's right but how does
that
how can you do that without a comma
what am i missing
that's why i'm not good at chess i can
only go five bites buffalo what you
really should ask is like how can you do
it without capital letters oh yeah oh
shoot because buff come full circle we
freaking we freaking derived why you
need capital letters uppercase letters
are necessary because of this sentence
uppercase they're okay so you know that
it's the we're talking about this the
town of buffalo
and not the animal or the verb
oh yeah because here it is with
buffalo buffalo
you're just saying buffalo dude
yo your emphasis helps a little bit but
i mean buffalo anyone who like there's
so few people who care about this
buffalo new york buffalo
buffalo buffalo
buffalo
buffalo
buffalo new york buffalo there's
there's three there's two verbs in a row
because they buffalo
you see there see that that's it no
that's a v i can see it
it's there's not there can't be two
verbs in it it's proper noun
adjective
no no see
we go to the wiki i believe we have it
go to the wiki that's called buffalo
buffalo buffalo buffalo buffalo buffalo
buffalo buffalo
and then you'll learn all about it okay
i'm exhausted let's end this i yeah i
mean i had a lot of fun i mean there's a
reason why it's today i learned
and the implication is that it's only
one thing it's like once you learn the
one thing it's like you hang it up for
that that's been my philosophy i just
got to say it once i learned the one
thing i'm done for the day i had an
incredible time
i
much prefer this method
okay just so just so you know in terms
of what i'm only speaking for myself i'm
talking about you you're talking about
the 188 earpod one i much prefer hearing
your voice than just reading your tweet
yeah you got to really mean it there's a
there's a barrier to entry and it's
personal and i like it
call in and let us know what you think
i'd like to be able to respond to some
of your responses and also be looking on
twitter but you know what you can also
use hashtag your biscuits because we're
we're not going to be reading that we're
still reading let me give my wreck yeah
you know what i'm changing it on the fly
this is a dynamic situation there's uh
could you example style
i recommend
if you have children
go ahead and start
lining them up on the wall and making
the tick marks it's never too late to
start do it today
do it today
and then when they have their friends
come over
get
do it to some of them too lando's on our
wall
i remember that
and then we kind of fell out of that he
needs to come back over and get measured
all right yeah i'll send him over
well i think i was measured too but i
was an adult
i'm not even on the wall i don't think
right because it's just intimidating hey
you need to start measuring your
shrinking
yup do it today take action
and don't forget to call 180 you're
really pushing it
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
you